un gran día en la lucha contra el
coronavirus así la compañía
estadounidense moderna acompaño su
anuncio de tener una vacuna experimental
94.5 efectiva en la prevención de ccoo y
19 saber que la vacuna va a ser efectiva
es una gran noticia pero todavía tenemos
que completar el proceso de regulación
que implica completar el estudio generar
más datos incluso algunos datos de
seguridad de seguimiento la compañía
estadounidense como hiso facer hace una
semana ha presentado sus resultados sin
publicar por el momento un estudio
científico completo revisado por
expertos independientes pero ya se sabe
que la vacuna de moderna requiere dos
dosis espaciadas 28 días una ventaja
clave es que no necesita un
almacenamiento ultra frío como la de
facer lo que facilita su distribución
los datos del ensayo de moderna en el
que participaron 30 mil voluntarios
mostraron también que la vacuna prevenía
los casos de ccoo y 19 graves una
cuestión que aún se discute con la
vacuna de fallo sin embargo el director
general de la ms calmó el optimismo que
ya había generado el anuncio de fashion
tech
sabíamos que una vacuna sería
fundamental para controlar la pandemia
razón por la cual la oms se propuso
acelerar esta acción pero es importante
enfatizar que una vacuna complementará a
las otras herramientas que tenemos y no
las reemplazará una vacuna por sí sola
no acabará con la pandemia will not and
that pandemic la comisión europea ya
anunció que el bloque está trabajando
para firmar acuerdos de suministro de la
vacuna por su parte junto con la vacuna
de fase de eeuu podría tener más de mil
millones de dosis solo de los dos
fabricantes más de lo necesario para los
330 millones de residentes del país